hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book eight of saint augustine's
confessions there is an incredibly
important turning point that i think
many people remember with this crisis
happening in the garden and augustine is
in great anguish finding himself you
know kind of divided but there is
something that helps to precipitate that
that is narrated in chapter 6 and
chapter 7 which is this encounter
with a guy who comes over and his name
is ponta chianus kind of a mouthful
there to talk and he narrates something
that produces a crisis
for augustine and i think that we need a
little bit
of context to
make sense of this
augustine has been questing for a long
time ever since he says he read cicero's
hortensius that awakened him not just a
philosophy but the desire for wisdom he
is looking for
a way to understand himself to
understand god to understand the human
condition to understand the universe and
to direct
himself to direct not just his behavior
but his loves what it is that he should
be
effectively oriented towards and so he
has been living this common life with
his friends for a while we could mention
olympias who gets brought up a lot in
the confessions there's others as well
and they are living a common life that
is oriented towards some higher
goods towards justice and the virtues
towards
trying to understand god towards trying
to free themselves of the life that they
had been stuck in before and to their
own friendship with each other and it's
a pretty good life it's not quite a
monastic life but it's it's something
you could say on the way to it it's what
we would nowadays call an intentional
community a community of friendship
and so this guy
ponte chianis comes to
visit
he's augustine says that
you know i was frequenting your church a
lot i had all these friends and then we
have uh this this fellow
pontiquianus a country man of ours in so
far as being from africa being from
north africa right uh who held a high
office at court i don't know what he
wanted from us but as we sat down to
talk together he chanced to notice a
book a book that was laying on a gaming
table and this is a very interesting
thing that we should have a little bit
of a digression about
it's a book
by who by paul paul the apostle
why would there be a book by itself
not part of a big bound codex that we
call the bible
well because when augustine is talking
about the christian scriptures he
doesn't mean necessarily one big book
that contains them all
there were all of these different books
that would circulate independently of
each other and might be read for their
own sake so a book by paul would be one
of the many letters that paul has has
written and so uh ponte chianis notices
this
opens it up and
found to his surprise it was by the
apostle paul he thought it was one or
other of the books that i was wearing
myself out in teaching so books of
rhetoric books of literature books of
philosophy and so he smiles and looks at
me as if to congratulate me and
expressed surprise that he suddenly
found these writings and these alone
before my eyes why because ponte kianis
is a christian and so he's like oh this
is cool i mean augustine are you
actually a christian are you just
somebody interested in christianity
you're reading a good part of it right
here you know
and so
augustine says i told him how i expended
very great pains on those scriptures and
then he says a discussion
came up in which he narrated the story
of anthony so
ponte kianis goes into several different
discourses here that augustine talks
about
one is talking about the life of anthony
and ponte kianis is he narrating the
entire life of anthony maybe probably
not probably some of the key ideas and
then maybe explaining it along the way
maybe augustine gets to ask some
questions who is anthony
anthony is an egyptian monk
why does it matter that he's an egyptian
monk is it well you know he's located
far away
well at that time as we know by looking
at other writers
monasticism was taking off in a lot of
places and one of the places where it
was considered particularly austere
was egypt as a matter of fact when john
cassian around this time and his buddy
are leaving the western area and going
to palestine to study with the monks
there the monks in palestine are like oh
you know we're serious but you want to
see some serious monasticism you got to
go to egypt man check those guys out
right and so the life of saint anthony
is talking not just about this guy saint
anthony but about the monastic way of
life
right
so
augustine goes on and says his name was
famous among your servants but up to
that very hour had been unknown to us
when he discovered this he dwelt all the
more on the subject introducing the
great man to those of us who were
ignorant of him and we stood in
amazement on hearing such wonderful
works of yours deeds of recent memory
done so close to our own times and most
fully testified to all of us marveled
why not only because there had been such
great wonders but because we hadn't
heard of it and this is a common
experience isn't it you get introduced
to some great philosopher or some
literary figure or some you know
philanthropist you're like how did i not
know about this and well the answer is
you weren't reading the right books or
you weren't in the right circles
then ponta chianus brings it a little
bit closer to home
so there's this cool guy out in the
desert who you know we've got a life of
you know there's actually people
right here in in your own environment
who are doing
similar things he says from this subject
his discourse turned to the flocks
within the monasteries and augustine is
actually using that term monasterium
right
and to their way of life and it's it's
not just the fact that people are going
into monasteries that's less interesting
than where
how in what way they're living
and augustine has a great metaphor here
to you which is like a sweet smelling
odor to you and to the fruitful deserts
in the wilderness of all of which we
knew nothing
there was a monastery at milan a city
that augustine
knows right there was a monastery at
milan filled with good brothers situated
outside the walls under the fostering
care of ambrose the bishop but we had
not known about it
he proceeded with his account and we
kept silent and attentive so now we've
got two things being talked about listen
there's monks nearby you know there's
monks in the desert of egypt cool story
about one of them
by the way
i myself
ran into a house like this and i saw
two
uh
worldly men
get converted
so he says
he told us how three and
he and three of his associates uh it was
that tree or one afternoon went out for
a walk in the gardens along the walls
they chanced to walk in pairs one went
apart with him the other two wandered
off by themselves so the other two
find a house it's translated as house a
cottage really a little tiny place a
casa in trier
and uh his these two buddies go in
and there they found a little book in
which was written the life of anthony so
the life of anthony shows up twice in
this story one of them began to read
this book to marvel at it and to be
aroused by it as he read it he began to
meditate on taking up such a life now
this you could say well this is a
midlife crisis right
these are successful people they're
actually like special agents agentus in
rabus right uh so they they're they're
important guys they've got careers and
they read this book and so the one reads
it and he's like
you know
my life is kind of a waste actually
he says the reader suddenly filled with
holy love and sober shame now here's
something really interesting
made angry with himself
turned his eyes upon his friend and said
tell me i ask you
where will we get by all these laborers
of ours what are we seeking for what
purpose do we serve in office what
higher ambition can we have at court
than to become friends of the emperor is
this what we want or do we want
something
better for ourselves
let's let's quit let's
let's join up here let's let's become
monks let's live like
saint anthony and there's again it's
mentioned this anger as he read and
turned upon the waves of his heart he
raged at himself for a while but then
discerned better things and determined
upon them this is a common experience
where how could i have been so
so stupid right
what's going on with me you know this is
a common experience in spiritual life
interestingly i mentioned john cassian
earlier john cassian is a little more
restrictive about anger than augustine
himself is and john cassian says the
only kind of anger that's good is the
anger you feel towards yourself and at
your sins and your own anger and that's
what these guys are feeling
and so
they've decided to change their lives
now ponta chianus and his companion
arrive
and as he says
they are themselves changed
but they um
he says in no wise changed from their
although in no ways changed for their
first form of state nevertheless wept
over it as he affirmed congratulated
them devoutly recommended themselves to
their prayers so ponta kianis gonna
continue on doing what he does
now
very very interesting what sort of
effect does this story have on augustine
we can think about possible effects that
this could have you could be like
you know the proverbial cool story bro
which is dismissive oh i don't care
about this silly story of you know
people changing their lives and all that
augustine has the opposite reaction he
takes it
to heart
he tells us it's the beginning of
chapter seven
ponte kianis told us this story and as
he spoke you
oh lord turn me back on myself
so this metaphor here is a spatial
metaphor augustine is you know looking
out he's his hearing is going out to the
world and to other things and god has
augustine turned in
converted you could say
upon himself
and uh you know augustine says i didn't
really want to look on myself you stood
me face to face with myself
so that
i can see why how i actually am how foul
i was how deformed how defiled how
covered with stains and sores i looked
and i was filled with horror and you
know
what's the natural reaction to that i
don't want to look at this where can i
where could i go instead and he says
there was no place for me to flee to
away from myself
i tried to turn my gaze from myself but
ponta kiana still went on with the story
that he was telling and once again you
placed me in front of myself and thrust
me before my own eyes so that i could
see how badly off
i was and augustine isn't really that
badly off right he says
many years had flown by since we know
when i was reading cicero's hortensius i
was aroused to a zeal for wisdom but i
delayed to despise earthly happiness and
devote myself to that search i wanted it
so to speak have it all i want to like
look for wisdom but i also want to you
know as we would say screw around
quite literally one of the problems for
augustine as we hear him later on saying
is you know give me chastity
incontinence but not yet i'd still like
to have some some sex from time to time
that comfort right and so
augustine is is you know wavering
between these things and when it comes
to that prayer he says i feared you
would hear me quickly and that quickly
you would heal me of that disease of
lust which i wish to have satisfied
rather than
extinguished and so this is what
augustine
is
feeling
thinking
trying to figure out as he's listening
to ponta chianis talking about these
monks people who have made a decision to
leave those things behind and to devote
themselves as exclusively as they can to
loving and understanding god and indeed
serving their neighbors within the
monastery so augustine this is part of
what is going to precipitate that famous
scene
in the garden where he's he's wavering
back and forth it's interesting we
should close this out how the stories
that others tell us stories in this case
that incorporate others stories
can have such a profound effect on us
at the right time
not necessarily
in a
universal catch-all applies to everybody
at every point in time way
they're instead stories that hit us at
the right point
and then can allow as augustine says god
to act within
our lives our thoughts our affections
and to
be drawn into seeing ourself
not in the story that's being told but
in the implications
of the story the story even though it's
not about us
applies to us and that is what happens
in this
famous
uh set of passages within these two
chapters in book eight
you